hey you guys it's max with Max Tech
today we're gonna be comparing the
iPhone 11 Pro max against the brand new
Google pixel for Excel we're going to
look at a wide variety of things such as
the design build quality the displays
the speaker loudness and quality
performance cameras and much more this
video is sponsored by Squarespace an
all-in-one platform that makes it
extremely easy to make an amazing
website let's start off with build
quality and design I definitely prefer
the look of the iPhone 11 Pro max it
looks more premium with the stainless
steel frame that is more durable than
the aluminum frame of the pixel for the
camera bump in my opinion looks much
better than the pixel of force and along
with that it just looks like it's nicer
and more premium but I like the feel of
the pixel for better the matte glass is
actually more satin like somewhere
between glossy and matte whereas the
iPhones is completely matte and it's a
lot more slick now along with that the
frame of the pixel 4 has a little bit
more grip as well it kind of has this
textured feeling and the actual phone
itself is actually slimmer than the
iPhone 11 Pro max making it feel more
comfortable in the hand flipping over to
the side the pixel 4 has all of its
buttons on the right hand side we have
the power button and the volume rocker
and I actually prefer this because I can
control everything with my thumb and
it's perfect since I'm right-handed
whereas the iPhone has a larger power
button on the side which is definitely
nicer to have it be larger than the
small one and then your volume rocker is
on the left side and included with that
we have this physical silent switch
which I really like and I wish the pixel
offered now along with that the quality
of the buttons are much better on the
iPhone they feel like they're more
clicky more consistent where the pixels
buttons feel kind of mushy we also have
some major differences on the front the
iPhone has that notch that a lot of
people don't like but the pixel 4 goes
for a different method altogether
skipping the notch but giving us this
very big forehead that houses all the
new sensors the pixel for does have
slimmer bezels on the side but the chin
is also larger at the bottom and it no
longer has that front facing speaker of
course the iPhone has a Lightning port
instead of USB type-c and neither of
these phones have a headphone
but the iPhone does give you lightning
earpods inside of the box where the
pixel doesn't give you any headphones as
for battery capacity the pixel 4 has a
3700 milliamp hour battery compared to
30 969 in the iPhone now you would
expect that the battery life would be
quite similar or the battery size is so
close but in fact we have a massive
difference the pixel 4 gets roughly 5 to
5 and a half hours of screen on time
just the way it's set up out of the box
compared to 8 to 8 and a half with the
iPhone 11 Pro max that is a huge
difference so both these phones have a
bunch of sensors and the four heads or
inside the notch here that allows the
phone to accurately and securely unlock
your phone the iPhone has had that for a
while and you just look at it it shows a
lock and you have to swipe to get to
your home screen whereas with the pixel
4 it will actually do automatically for
you as you guys can see it is very fast
and very convenient I love the fact that
the pixel 4 gives you this option
I really wish Apple would let us have
that as well now one other difference is
that the pixel 4 has their soli radar
sensor built in the benefit of the radar
for face unlock is that as soon as you
reach for your phone it will actually
know that you're reaching for and it'll
turn on all of the sensors and that
speeds up the face unlocking process
let's compare the speed of the face
unlock so right now the pixel isn't
unlocking automatically and I'm just
gonna press on the button as I type and
swipe on the iPhone and as you guys
could tell it definitely is a lot faster
and most of the time you don't have to
do anything as soon as you pick it up
it's unlocked
maybe so one interesting thing with this
radar sensor is that it is not always
working properly maybe it just needs
more software optimization but one
feature that allows you to do is skip
songs and do different gestures but what
I found in the real world is that a lot
of the times the gestures aren't
properly recognized that one does have
better range with his face and lock
sensors I set both on the desk in front
of me and if I press down in the iPhone
as you guys could see it did a lock but
the pixel if I press down all we get is
a little shaking lock icon meaning it
can't recognize my face let me give a
shout-out to our sponsor Squarespace
I've built many websites using
Squarespace and been recommending them
for over five years
and I've tried making websites from
scratch using custom templates and
different platforms and Squarespace is
by far my most recommended method
whether you want to build a portfolio
site ecommerce blog or anything else
they have got you covered with great
cross-platform designs to choose from
and built-in security certificates and
SEO tools this means that your website
will rank much better in searches and
that's all included for one low price
meaning that Squarespace is not only
easy to use and fantastic looking but an
amazing value as well head to
squarespace.com slash max tech for a no
credit card required trial and to get
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a domain now let's compare the
displays the pixel 4 has a higher
resolution that means more pixels per
inch and also has a slightly smaller
screen 6.3 inches compared to 6.5 now in
the real world if I take a close look at
the icons or even if I open up a web
page it is very difficult to see the
difference because the iPhone is a
Retina display meaning it's already high
enough resolution to not be able to tell
a difference now both of them do have a
white balance adjustment automatically
ambient EQ for the pixel 4 or true tone
for the iPhone that means that the
wipeouts will change depending on your
lighting and that is very nice to have
now let's talk about display brightness
I match these up identically and what's
very interesting is the difference in
the actual brightness setting the iPad
11 Pro max is actually less than 50%
brightness whereas the pixel 4 is
probably around the 80% mark and that
means we're pushing more power to this
display here and the pie is draining
more battery now if we go ahead and max
both of these out and I do have auto
brightness turned off we could tell that
the iPhone is way brighter you can
really tell the difference here when we
adjust our cameras exposure so they're
not blowing out the screens this is the
biggest disappointment about the fix
before for me personally not the lack of
ultra wide lens or battery life the fact
that when you're outside it is very
difficult to see the screen and that's a
lot of reflections because of this I
pretty much always have to have the
pixel 4s display completely maxed out
compared to having the iPhones at around
70% which also leads to worse battery
life for the pixel the big safor does
one trick up its sleeve and that is the
90 Hertz refresh rate of the display
this means that when it is working
everything is super smooth and of course
paired with these faster animations it
looks really nice and pleasant to use
now one issue that it is having is that
the 90 Hertz is actually not working the
majority of the time it cuts down to 60
Hertz to save battery life so when it is
on it is nice and you notice it but when
it's off there is no difference now
Google did say that they're gonna put
out a patch to allow the 90 Hertz screen
to work more often but of course that is
gonna further impact battery life
because of this when watching videos the
iPhone has better brightness and
contrast at the same time which
definitely beats out the slightly
sharper image of the pixel for screen
now let's compare the speakers
[Music]
[Music]
keep in mind that what you're hearing is
going through a microphone or a corridor
through compression and depending on
your speakers you won't hear the same
thing that we're hearing but based on
what we can hear the pixel for has a lot
more mids they're really pushing the
volume of the mids but not so much the
highs or the lows whereas the iPhone
sounds more balanced but quieter vocals
are a lot more clear and overall the
actual balance of the sound is better in
terms of speakers the pixel four gives a
lot of volume out of the earpiece
speaker and kind of overpowers the
bottom one which is a first for us you
could definitely tell it's not blended
in together as well the iPhone made a
big jump with 11pro over the 10s to have
everything sound perfectly balanced
which makes it a better phone for a
surround sound but as far as output the
pixel four is a little bit louder now
let's get into performance the pixel
four has a Snapdragon 855 which is
getting close to a year old now whereas
the iPhone uses the new a 13 Bionic has
four gigs of ram compared to six gigs of
ram but of course iOS is a little bit
more efficient with its RAM management
and running Geekbench five we get a
pretty big difference in performance a
spar a single core the iPhone is more
than double the performance and in
multi-core the iPhone is more than 40
percent faster now in the real world you
can't really tell a difference when
you're opening apps or scrolling both of
them do a great job but that's going to
come and as far as future proofing and
along with that the iPod doesn't have to
work as hard to do regular tasks which
will help as far as battery life now as
far as graphics we would typically run
antutu but it just got updated for
Android and iOS but looking back at our
last test using the note 10 which has
the same graphics as the pixel for the
iPhone was 42% more powerful now if we
look at Geekbench 5s compute test which
tests a variety of different graphics
tasks the iPhone is more than three
times faster now this test does use
Apple's own metal API along with apples
graphics compared to Vulcan with Android
and this just shows off the efficiency
of having dedicated hardware and
software working together now let's talk
about the cameras Google added a
telephoto lens to the pixel 4 so now it
has 2
compared to three with the iPhone which
includes an ultra-wide lens now the
iPhone is definitely a big powerhouse in
terms of video it could shoot 4k 60 on
all of the cameras all the lenses
including the front-facing one where the
pixel can't shoot 4k 60 at all and it
can't shoot 4k on their front-facing
even at 30 frames per second
now the pixel does have one standout
feature that is Astro mode or Astro
photography which really makes images
look great if you're shooting at night
and you have a tripod now we do have a
full comparison between the pixel 4 and
the iPhone 11 pro max and along with
that the note 10 is in terms of photos
so if you guys want to see a very good
detailed comparison we will have that
linked at the end of this video the last
few differences in terms of hardware is
that the iPhone has Wi-Fi 6 which the
pixel 4 does not have and iPhone has
better waterproofing up to 13 feet for
30 minutes compared to 3 feet now
getting into the price both these start
with 64 gigabytes of ram the pixel for
excel comes in at $900 compared to $1100
for the iPhone now if you want more
storage than not the pixel 4 can go up
to 128 gigabytes for another hundred
dollars where the iPhone you need to
spend 150 but you end up getting 256
gigabytes of storage Apple also gives
you the choice to get up to 512
gigabytes of storage where with a pixel
you're limited at 128 and you cannot add
any extra because there is no SD card
slot now what is our final verdict well
if the operating system doesn't matter
to you we think that the iPhone 11 pro
max is definitely worth the extra cost
in terms of hardware it is better in
almost every single way as far as photos
it beats it out in most ways and video
is also a lot better the screen is
viewable outside and the difference in
battery life is substantial making it
the all-around better phone now if you
are somebody that's been using iPhones
for a while and say you're using an
older iPhone maybe all the way up to an
iPhone 10 and you know that you want to
switch to Android the pixel 4 will give
you the closest experience with Android
2 using iOS we have the face unlock we
have the new gestures just like iOS has
with the new iPhones the
look and design and feel is kind of
similar to an iPhone as well the
software is simple it works pretty well
so if that's where you're coming from
the pixel war it will give you a better
closer experience compared to one of the
other flagships that we think offer more
bang for the buck like the note 10 plus
or the 1 plus 7 Pro go ahead and give us
your opinions down in the comment
section below I want to hear your guys's
thoughts if you guys want to subscribe
click that little circle above and
enable notifications down below and
check out our photo and video
comparisons against these two that are
super detailed right over there the spin
max with Max sec and I'll see you in the
next video
[Music]